people are leaving flowers and other
tributes to justice ginsburg outside the
supreme court with the country bracing
for a political fight we don't want to
lose sight
of the meaning of justice ginsburg's
life her vision for this country
even in her descents was not about
division jan crawford looks at
ginsburg's legacy of raising people up
to help us all stand on common ground
all weekend the supreme court often the
site of protest
became a place of tribute seeing her
dissent
all the time and speak her own mind and
give thanks
going into the legal profession she
definitely paved the way for me
just knowing that if she was able to do
it then we can too
a true trailblazer justice ginsburg made
her mark on the law
even before she took a seat on the
supreme court
she graduated at the top of her class at
columbia law school
and learned firsthand about
discrimination
there was not a single firm in the
entire city of new york
that would offer me a job so she
leveraged the law to help
level the playing field as a lawyer for
the aclu ginsburg argued
six gender discrimination cases before
the supreme court
after 13 years as a federal appeals
court judge president clinton
nominated her to the high court in 1993.
on face the nation sunday clinton said
ginsburg knew
how to get it done she had the best
judgment
on when to work with others whenever she
could
and when to stand up when she couldn't
stand it
anymore as the court's leading liberal
ginsburg voted to protect abortion
rights
restrict the death penalty and expand
women's access to education and equal
pay
people asked me when would you be
satisfied with the number of women on
the court
when there were nine she had a long and
close friendship with a conservative
icon
the late justice antonin scalia ruth is
really bad only on the knee-jerk stuff
later in life ginsburg fought through
multiple bouts with cancer
at her side for 56 years of marriage
was her beloved husband marty who died
in 2010
she credited their happy marriage to a
piece of advice from her mother-in-law
she said dear in every good marriage
it helps sometimes
to be a little deaf and i have followed
that advice
not only in dealing with my dear spouse
but in dealing with my colleagues
but when ruth bader ginsburg spoke with
that soft voice
we all listened for cbs this morning
i'm jan crawford thank you jan crawford
i can't get enough guys of hearing about
her story her sense of humor
she was such a champion for equality on
and off the bench i love the deaf
comment what she said
and and just how she devoted her life to
helping others
pulling up others behind her one of the
things people were talking about over
the weekend which i found so fascinating
about her is she seemed
in person she seemed so measured and
proper but she was actually
fierce and radical and and it was it's
such an interesting contrast it was
fierce
fierce and radical but still polite in
her descents right still writing to win
in the long term she wanted to turn
people's minds and it was good to see
the the
the back and forth that she had with
aunt scalia too yes that the two of them
could sort of respectfully put each
other down but at the same time respect
and admire each other yeah
that was such a classic yeah i i always
loved that about about that i never got
a chance to meet her did you
no i didn't i never did i did once yeah
i interviewed her about about growing up
in the 1930s you did yeah it was a
wonderful visit
yeah not even no politics no law just
what was it like to be a kid
oh man that's great we gotta find that
yeah